how the heck do you get a job as a white
house photographer it seems like there
are so many photographers
uh throughout the country um
and uh you know photojournalism it's
something that makes me really sad
i'd love to talk to you about this too
where i feel like as a field
um it's shrinking in large part because
so many of these
newspapers are folding and that the
newspapers would be the primary
the magazines too the print magazines
so before we get into kind of the future
of photojournalism how did you
uh develop and then wind up with maybe
the highest profile
photojournalist gig in the world
well i mean let me preface this by
saying that given where we are today
which is
um you know not long after joe biden has
been elected
a lot of people reaching out to me
saying i want to be joe biden's
photographer
and you know and my response to them is
i i try to be blunt and go if
if joe biden doesn't know you
now he's not going to hire you you know
i mean there's
he's had a campaign photographer for the
last two years
you know that that's the guy that's
likely to get the job for me
uh i i just by you know sheer
coincidence these things happen in life
i was working for the chicago tribune i
was based in dc
in washington so when barack obama was
elected to the senate in 2004
uh jeff zeleny who was then a reporter
with washington bureau of the tribune
he and i documented obama's first year
in the senate
and i got access that nobody else got
because that was with the quote-unquote
hometown newspaper so i got to know him
on a professional
uh you know just in a professional way
but he also got a chance to see
how i worked you know which is you know
i like to say i work with
you know a small footprint and try not
to interfere with what's going on
um and and you know and he saw that i
took my job seriously
so you know skip ahead to four years he
gets elected president and asked me to
you know to be his white house
photographer so that's why it happened
for me
i'd imagine there were campaign
photographs
being taken all the time that was so
that was not you or that was you
2007 is when he started the campaign
because he started actually in february
2007
pretty you know pretty early and i
covered
probably the first three months of the
campaign
and then i quit i quit the trip tribune
because i thought
if they had just been bought by a real
estate magnet and
i didn't like the direction the
newspaper was going
i was uh you know i i just
didn't think that i could stomach it
anymore and even though
i sort of had to inside track to
covering his campaign i just could not
see myself working for the
the tribune anymore and i ended up
taking a a teaching job
photojournalism teaching job at ohio
university
um and then i would occasionally as a
freelancer
you know hook up with him on the
campaign drill um
so i sort of kept my foot in the door a
little bit
and then he wins in 2008 and then
you get the word hey come back to dc and
uh
become the white house photographer that
must have been quite a call
what was it from brock himself or was
that from someone on his team
you know gibbs was um kind of my main
contact
with obama and you know and robert gibbs
a lot of people you know just think of
him as the uh press secretary
but gibbs was one of the most
influential aides he was really
like sort of a senior advisor as well as
the press secretary so he
he was the one uh who called me on
behalf of the president-elect
he called me the night before classes
for the winter quarter where they
were supposed to begin and on a sunday
night and so the following
uh morning monday i walked into
my boss at ohio university and told him
that i was
leaving that afternoon for dc and i was
quite
quitting my job i
kind of have given them a heads up that
this might happen but you know you never
know until
until you get that call so then you
proceeded to spend
eight years as the white house for a
photographer uh
so i mean obviously you'd spend a lot of
time in dc so you're very familiar with
the environment
um but coming into the white house um
that must have been
an incredible journey where
you must have felt like you were
documenting history essentially
every day for
uh for eight years um what was that
adjustment like
and the other question i'd have is it
seems completely physically impossible
to me for any one human to cover
everything that happened in the white
house so is there like a whole team of
you
yeah i had a staff um my my approach
going in
was um that i
i was going to be all in every day
because
my attitude was if you were gonna
document for history
you a you can't predict when history is
gonna happen you know you don't yes
you don't always get noticed bowers no
yes um
but then also uh in terms of photography
you know i just felt the fleeting
moments
little moments the way he interacts with
certain people
uh if you're not there all the time
you're you're definitely not going to
make that picture and
so i wanted to make sure that i was all
there all the time
to make those fleeing moments because i
didn't ever want to miss any
so that's sort of the way i approached
uh the job and i i you know i knew what
i was in for
uh i don't think my wife knew what i
said before um because you know you kind
of put your personal life on hold for
and you know in my case for eight years
but um
you know i i did have a staff so it's
don't feel sorry for me because i could
have
easily you know taken a day off here and
there but
uh you know my attitude is just always
be there
so when does the day start and end for
you in that situation like i feel like
you'd want to live near the white house
just to be able to get there
yeah i didn't live that far i lived
about 15
20 minutes away and um i would try to
get there
you know one of the you know things that
we have to worry about
is staffers that he he doesn't really
have to worry about
is you know you got to commute you got
to get there whereas his commute was you
know two minutes
walk
so but i would try to get there at least
an hour before him
uh he would he would come down to the
oval office
sometime between nine and ten in the
morning uh so i tried to get there
you know about an hour before i did have
responsibilities as the head of my
office
and i would try to deal with those
either early in the morning or at the
end of the day
and then i would basically tag along
with him um
all day long until he went home for
dinner
and um you know and sometimes after
dinner he would come back to the west
wing or there'd be
events uh you know on the state floor or
outside of dc
that he would go to at night and so you
know every day was
you know a little different but pretty
much i would just
tag along with him you know at least 10
hours a day sometimes
15 sometimes longer so you you're
documenting him
people like me come in and people like
me you don't really remember because uh
i met
president obama um let's say
either three or four times something
like that um either in a group
or in a collective setting and you were
joking that like by the sixth picture
you might recognize someone again
i did get a picture every time i met him
which
was it was kind of nice it's like it was
just you're around him there oh there
were always these photographers trying
to capture the moment
um so and you don't even realize it when
you're the guest at that moment and so
then you just get the photo later and
you're like incredible
like all of my exchanges uh immortalized
um no you you probably have all sorts of
um crazy experiences and recollections
was there anything that you're able to
share about an experience where you were
like wow that just happened
for me a lot of the the wow moments were
not necessarily like the big event but
more um the the those moments that i
talked about those little moments
which really um define him
as a human being you know i mean like
for
i'll just this is just a for instance i
mean ben rhodes
um who you know was a deputy national
security advisor and
his daughter he he came in with his
daughter like around halloween time one
year
and she was just learning to crawl
and so obama gets down on
the rug of the old office squats down
and gets ella to crawl to him
and then he lies down on his back and
he's lifting her up
and you know those moments are just like
i can't believe this is happening as i'm
photographing this
um you know certainly the bin laden raid
and
big historic events like that obviously
are are also wow in a kind of different
way
where you sort of really feel the weight
of history taking place right in front
of you
um so um but you know i mean i think one
of the things that was
advantageous about being a seasoned
photographer photojournalist
is i was sort of able to to keep my
emotions in check
you know and not get so um
high if you will when when these uh when
these big moments are happening
just you know just sort of try to keep
my my level
pretty even so i'm not so overwhelmed by
what's happening that i'm still able to
make
you know pictures thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode